[Music]
despite being the eighth installment in
a long-running series the newest god of
war is a beast of its own it continues
the storyline of its predecessors but
revamps their combat pacing and flow it
takes their linear structure and morphs
it into an open-ended world and although
god of war effectively iterates on the
franchise's own identity it borrows from
many outside sources as well some of
which are more surprising than you might
think
Metroid and Castlevania Symphony of the
Night have inspired a multitude of games
this sub-genre affectionately called
Metroidvania x' features interconnected
worlds in which certain paths are
blocked until you unlock specific
abilities through backtracking and
exploration these games can integrate
story and gameplay into a much closer
relationship I recently spoke with Corey
Barr log gotta Wars creative director
over the phone and he mentioned Symphony
of the Night as one of the chief
influences throughout his development
career it's like the closest perfection
for me as a gamer the beginning of the
game setting you up to lose everything
and desire to get back and get it back
better than ever that is resonated and
stuck with me for so long that it
influences everything that I do so you
know like the metroidvania design a lot
to be is something that I think is
deeply rooted in the way that I approach
all problem God of War is full of
enticing dead ends and secrets just out
of reach as in Metroidvania as you're
learning new layers of god of war at a
steady pace each new ability allows you
to reevaluate the world you traverse
every area again seeing your
surroundings through a new lens certain
puzzles now make sense old enemies
reveal new weaknesses whole side areas
open up beckoning you forward teasing
new pathways that may or may not require
further learning to progress it's one of
those rare games that makes backtracking
fun another recent third-person action
game put the metroidvania formula to
good use
2015's rise of the Tomb Raider uses
similar item gating to funnel you
through its world in fact it does so
almost right away pitting you against a
vicious grizzly bear only letting you
get by it once you learn to craft poison
arrows once past the bear a whole new
sandbox area opens up cue the
exploration rise of the Tomb Raider and
God of War have more in common than this
overall structure though bar log was
lead animator on God of War and Game
Director for God of War 2 he worked on
God of War 3 for nine months before
leaving Sony Santa Monica for a new
project that project was the 2013 Tomb
Raider reboot this game also uses a
light
Metroidvania approach morphing the
linear legacy of Tomb Raider
into one of sandbox level design two
years later Metroidvania aspects became
even more prevalent in the sequel
subsequently several of rise of the tomb
Raider's designers moved over to God of
War during the latter's creation because
of this there's a fair amount of osmosis
between the two projects as bar walk
says the video game industry is one big
melting pot of ideas games that bleed
into other games projects that iterate
on those that came before them if you
dig deep enough into any new release
you'll find the DNA of dozens of other
games but there are structural
similarities between rise of the Tomb
Raider and God of War
like the Crystal Dynamics project god of
war makes use of a massive hub
connecting smaller side areas each time
you return to the lake of nine you have
more abilities to use expanding the
world with new areas and reinforcing
your knowledge of existing ones it
brings you closer to the world and the
characters you're spending so much time
with and speaking of characters that
brings us to the Last of Us bar log has
spoken extensively about Joel and
Ellie's influence on his game the
relationship between Naughty Dog's
iconic duo is the centerpiece of the
Last of Us and the dynamic between
Kratos and his son is a pillar of God of
War
their journeys affect them not just as
individuals but also as teams that grow
alongside each other they fall down they
pick each other back up in speaking with
bar log there are numerous inspirations
that help god of war take shape some of
them lie outside video games such as the
film's rope Birdman or hard-boiled
movies that make use of long takes to
bring in immediacy to the ongoing story
then there are characters such as Quint
from Jaws or Adrian Monk who inspired
some of god of wars more colorful
personalities and of course there's the
Norse mythology that fuels the series
new narrative but in the end God of War
is a thing of its own separate not just
from its outside inspirations but from
its franchise predecessors as well it
brings an array of new mechanics to the
table it functions as a sequel to the
older God of War games and it works as a
beginning to a new saga it is more than
just the sum of its parts
once the credits have finally rolled
it's pretty clear God of War may have
began on the shoulders of giants but now
it's become a giant of its own
[Music]
you
[Music]